Over two decades before Buzz and Neil put
their feet on the Moon, humans were already
preparing for that day by sending other living
organisms to space.
In 1947, the United States blasted fruit flies
into space in a captured Nazi V-2 rocket.
Alongside packets of rye and cotton seeds,
the original intention of the flies’ mission
was to determine the effects of cosmic rays
on living organisms.
When the flies’ canister parachuted back
to Earth, scientists were relieved to find
the fruit flies still alive.
In 1948, America took the next step and sent
a monkey to space.
This didn’t go as well.
Albert I, a rhesus monkey, was anesthetized
before even being put on the V-2 Blossom.
While the rocket launched successfully, scientists
later speculated that Albert probably wasn’t
alive for the flight due to having likely
suffocated in the very cramped capsule before
takeoff.
Even if he was alive for the trip, with the
rocket only reaching 39 miles (62 km) in altitude,
the parachute mechanism failed and the rocket
had a violent crash landing, which would have
likely killed him.
At least the name “Albert” lived on because,
from that point on, the proceeding tests involving
monkeys in the United States were known as
the “Albert project.”
Albert II’s fate was no better, though he
was given more breathing room and survived
the flight.
But after reaching a maximum altitude of 83
miles, officially crossing the Kármán line
becoming the first primate in space, he died
upon impact when the parachutes failed.
Alberts III through V all were sent into space
and none survived, either due to impact, mid-air
explosion or a complication during the flight.
Until 1959, no primate had ever returned to
Earth from space alive.
Meanwhile in the Soviet Union, the Russians
were sending a different type of animal into
the great unknown.
Around the same time the Americans were performing
their monkey experiments, the Russians were
sending rabbits, mice and rats.
Then, they decided dogs were the next logical
step due to, as Vladimir Yazdovsky, the head
of the biological program for space research
at the Institute for Aviation Medicine in
Moscow, said: “We selected dogs as biological
objects because their psychology is very well-studied,
they adapt well to training, are very communicative,
and social with people.”
It also helped that dogs were readily available,
with Moscow awash with stray canines at the
time.
In August of 1951, Dezik and Tsygan (meaning
“Gypsy”) was launched into the sky.
After going to an altitude of 62 miles (100
km), the capsule with the two canines crashed
rather hard on Earth, leaving Russian scientists
fearing the worst.
When they opened the capsule, however, barking
greeted them.
Dezik and Tsygen were the first beings (besides
fruit flies and perhaps microbes) to go into
space and return to Earth safely – save
for a little motion sickness.
Over the next eight years, the Soviets sent
many dogs to space, of which a good portion
came back to Earth alive and relatively well.
Famously, in 1957, a pup named Laika became
the first to circle the Earth.
Whether Laika was actually still alive during
that first orbit is a source of much debate,
with her early death likely due to overheating
and panic, though it should be noted that,
sadly, there were no plans to recover Laika
after the orbit.
One of the scientists involved in Laika’s
mission, Oleg Gazenko, later stated of this,
“Work with animals is a source of suffering
to all of us…
The more time passes, the more I’m sorry
about it.
We shouldn’t have done it…
We did not learn enough from this mission
to justify the death of the dog.”
While the Russians certainly did have success
with canines, dogs are a far cry from humans.
Primates, on the other hand, are in the same
family.
Determined to finally get their own efforts
right, NASA choose two monkeys for its next
mission in 1959.
The first was another female rhesus monkey
named Able.
Picked from a lot of 24 that came from a zoo
in Independence, Kansas, Able was chosen for
the mission with direct orders from President
Eisenhower.
This was due to the original primate space
cadet being Indian-born and, since some in
India consider the rhesus monkey sacred, President
Eisenhower thought it would be best for political
reasons to send an American-born rhesus monkey
to space instead.
The second monkey chosen for the mission was
also selected from a large group, this time
of 25, purchased from a pet shop in Miami.
The two year old, one pound South American-born
Miss Baker was determined to be the best of
the bunch, due to her propensity to not seem
to mind being confined for long periods, her
docile nature, intelligence, seeming to enjoy
being handled, and general friendliness towards
humans, with her nickname becoming “TLC”
(Tender Loving Care).
With the selections made, the two monkeys
were sent into training for their date with
history.
AbleEach monkey was fitted with specially
made suits with sensors to track pulse, body
temperature and movement.
Able’s was tightly fitted, allowing for
minimal movement, but giving her enough room
to perform a simple task on the flight- she
was trained to press a button whenever a red
light flashed, so that the humans below could
test her coordination and focus while in space.
Miss Baker’s suit was lined with foam rubber
and leather and she was fitted into a very
small life support capsule, nearly the size
of a thermos, which gave her no room to move.
Both monkeys had fiberglass helmets.
At 2:35 a.m. on May 28, 1959, the giant Jupiter
AM-18 blasted into the sky, reaching speeds
in excess of 10,000 mph, with the two primates
seated not-so-comfortably in the nose cone.
Their flight lasted about 17 minutes before
they plunged into the ocean about 250 miles
southeast of San Juan, Puerto Rico.
The recovery team immediately went in search
of them.
Initially, there was fear that the capsule
had sunk, much like a predecessor of theirs.
But then the crew spotted it bobbing in the
water.
Shortly thereafter, a message came through
to the Cape Canaveral control room, “Able
Baker perfect.
No injuries or other difficulties.”
The two monkeys had become the first primates
to travel in space and return home safely.
Miss_BakerAble and Miss Baker arrived back
to the United States to a hero’s welcome,
first going to their own private officer quarters
with recently installed air conditioning.
Then, they were flown to Washington DC for
a “welcome back” press conference.
There, correspondents “pushed each other
and clambered over chairs to get closer,”
to the monkeys reported The New York Times.
As for the heroes themselves, “the monkeys
were far less excited than the humans.
They munched peanuts and crackers.”
Able and Miss Baker were awarded medals and
merits.
A month later, they were on the cover of LIFE
Magazine.
For Able, unfortunately, fame was short lived.
It was supposed to be a minor operation, one
simply to remove leftover electrodes from
the trip four days earlier.
Doctors were very careful with her, but after
administering anesthesia, the monkey inexplicably
went into cardiac arrest and stopped breathing.
After spending nearly two hours attempting
to save Able’s life, the doctors working
on her accepted the inevitable- she was gone.
Able died on June 1, 1959, only days after
returning home.
Today, she’s preserved and on display at
the National Air and Space Museum in Washington
DC.
miss-baker-birthdayAs for Miss Baker, she
went on to live a life worthy of an American
hero.
After her media blitz, she retired to the
Naval Air Training Station in Pensacola in
a custom built home.
Three years later, she was “married” to
a Peruvian squirrel monkey called “Big George”
in a nice naval ceremony.
In 1971, the happy couple moved to U.S. Space
and Rocket Center in Huntsville, Alabama.
In 1979, Big George died but, after a brief
mourning period, Miss Baker remarried.
In a ceremony in Huntsville, she took her
second vows with a monkey named Norman.
Fitted with
a wedding dress, Miss Baker tore it off, apparently
not much for formal wear.
Five years later, on November 29, 1984, Miss
Baker died, living to the ripe old age of
27.
In addition to being a space explorer, Miss
Baker was also the oldest living squirrel
monkey on record.
For reference, the average lifespan of a squirrel
monkey in the wild is just 15 years and in
captivity around 20.
Three hundred people, and Norman, attended
the funeral in Huntsville, Alabama, on the
grounds of the United States Space & Rocket
Center.
She’s buried at the Space Center with an
often-visited marker.
Miss_Baker's_GravestoneWhile Miss Baker and
Able may not get the same recognition as Buzz
Aldrin and Neil Armstrong, they are, perhaps,
among the most famous monkeys in history,
getting the chance to do something most humans
only ever dream about.